alors christophe j'aimerais maintenant
qu'on profite de vos lumières sur le
monde footballistique et qu'on fasse une
interview tir aux pigeons
[Musique]
karim benzema
écoutez j'ai été très dur avec lui s'il
est condamné s'il est condamné je pense
qu'il faudrait être dur avec lui dans la
sanction pour l'instant pour l'instant
on peut pas se faire une opinion et
condamner quelqu'un c'est son métier
c'est sa vie le foot l'empêcher de faire
un championnat d'europe seulement pour
des choses qui sont sortis dans la
presse didier deschamps il peut faire
gagner la france à l'euro deschamps il
peut faire gagner tout le monde a un peu
mais nous faire gagner l'eurovision
didier deschamps
[Applaudissements]
dès qu ils véhiculent une chance autour
de lui
donc voilà il peut tout faire gagner il
est comme pas dakhla qu'il arrive à
parler sans bouger les verts
hatem ben arfa alors voilà qu'à un
gâchis quand même non c'est incroyable
il ya une époque du gâchis c'était moi
je crois que là je crois que là du
gâchis c'est venu maintenant c'est alors
qu'ils ont dit qu'ils devraient
aujourd'hui les à nice il fait les
bonnes heures de glisse il devrait être
au barça il devrait être real madrid
devrait être le plus le plus grand
joueur français malheureusement il ne
l'est pas 27 ans est pas encore trop
tard mais il est plus près de la fin que
du début alors vincent labrune est ce
que c'est pas le finalement le le pire
directeur de club qu'est l'om
je ne le connais pas je n'en sais rien
voilà tout n'est pas réussi à marseille
c'est compliqué c'est un club tellement
compliqué est ce qu'il y a un président
ou un dirigeant qui a réussi à marseille
sincères martha big en même temps oui à
l'époque mais honnêtement
serge aurier
c'est je comprends pas il vient de dire
dugarry la grosse [ __ ] voix
sur twitter bon lionel messi a un à dire
c'est le meilleur joueur de tous les
temps pour de tous les temps voilà ouais
ouais ça nous tue ca de tous les temps
[Rires]
zidane c'est votre copain je vous
demande pas est-ce qu'il va y arriver à
l'objectif je le souhaite après c'est
les clubs d'être compliqué ouais moi
mais je pense qu'il vaut mais entraîner
le real madrid même pour une première
expérience que sochaux oui jobs oui le
meilleur joueur du monde veut et même
plus simple alors samir nasri à
la génération je m'excuse il s'est
excusé il s'est excusé je me souviens je
crois que c'était alors au dernier aux
roues s'est excusé et trois jours a pris
la relève mais c'est ça alors on termine
avec christophe dugarry vous en pensez
quoi de christophe dugarry
gens pensent pas grand chose en effet
moi je viens non mais je veux je suis
heureux je suis heureux dans ma vie et
puis voilà les choses ça va vous avez là
en tous les cas merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu